have a lot of stuff to talk about today
first of all in terms of software we've
just done all the hardware store now
we're going to jump into software the
first folks to talk about Bethesda last
year they did their first III conference
it ended up being the e3 conference I
mean between showing fallout for
enhancing its saying it was coming out
later that year pitboy edition launching
a mobile game Doom like the amount of
insane stuff that they showed at that I
mean dishonored it was it was an
obstacle by runner and looking at this
year there was a lot of rumors about
some of the stuff that may or may not
see first one I want to talk about which
you Dave Skyrim remastered I feel like
I've heard this rumor for the past three
years at e3 it's either happening this
year or it's not happening at all right
yeah I mean we've heard about so many
times and I mean I'd love to jump back
into that world again but the same time
I feel like it's also maybe not the most
deserving Elder Scrolls game maybe a bit
of a controversial opinion right I mean
would you prefer to see oblivion guys
I'm the wind oh really okay I'm fair
enough I mean the way I look means a
dagger fault or arena either either
remaster a game that isn't only five
years old yeah because everyone's
already played Skyrim to death and it
still looks amazing especially with mods
but you either remaster a game that's
like way inaccessible now like morrowind
yeah or you explore the rest of Tammy L
like you go to Black Isle the home of
the argonians and see what they're doing
all right I'm gonna be the mr. Bethesda
in the suit and be like talk some sense
into you and be Skyrim is the most
successful of the Elder Scrolls series
then it would be right it would be
exactly and if you were going to
remaster anyone you pick the one that
people have current nostalgia for right
you know it's still in the consciousness
of gamers socially you know arrow to the
knee means oh god I'm still going Skyrim
mods are what paved the way for Fallout
mods yeah and Bethesda's kind of
interested in delivering mods across
platforms and they have a crap ton of
mods already ready to go right they've
just launched obviously fallout months
so they know how the flow works the
pipeline works yeah but that stuff at
all it's almost as if fallout 4 months
which was kind of worked out in order to
bring Skyrim mods
yeah because I mean it's got so much
legacy to it and to be honest like
everyone loves Skyrim like we have
nostalgia for for Morrowind oblivion and
that kind of stuff but like the amount
of people that still talk about skyrim
right now and I just like as soon as you
announced it I will throw my money at
you and just posting pictures of fry
from futurama being like take my money
like this millions of mother it makes
perfect sense for him to do oblivion and
Skyrim instead of believe it wasn't
until you mentioned morrowind or even
like you wanna feel really old it's been
10 years since oblivion came out there's
a man sounds like one of the first games
I bought on a love that game yeah imma
get mad getting a thick box version I
want yeah it looked like a friggin
manuscript is awesome I was actually the
idiot that bought horse armor as well oh
you were I did yeah at the start of DLC
old it has I said that they pretty much
have done Skyrim they got over it was
Jerry a while back like yeah we poured
it we've done totally so I think that's
running on xbox yeah like enough people
it's seen as you know some sort of
channels that even last year I was like
oh it's definitely yeah it was it was
clearly something they kind of used to
explore developing for these consoles
hmm and we're like know if we just hit
press discs we were imagine how good
that rain and water would look that
morrowind dankness HD and let's move on
though cuz we got a bunch of games to go
through here at doom release last month
massive surprise successes so well
excessive it was half a million sometime
last week it's probably pushed way past
our now as well and that's only on PC do
you think we'll see some DLC for this
thing like best-case scenario we'll get
some single-player dlc where I case
scenario we'll get some multiplayer DLC
totally totally totally with you honor
yeah Dave what do you think I mean I've
played into the ending and no spoilers
but the ending was like you'll see more
of us okay right so I mean it's pretty
implied we'll see more of doom but like
Tom said the single player was one of
the best shooter snore ease that I've
played in years but the multiplayer I
was just like yeah it's totally got
developed by different you know his
critical assembly who did it or a sort
of of call of duty and halo you know
multiplayer side project fame and I yeah
it was nothing wrong with it's just it's
so it's like yes it's so blase from the
single-player experience yeah
like we've figured out how to boil doom
back down to its essence we want to
remind you what first-person shooters
like this why you love them and give
that Anna multiplayer room this modern
crap you've got yeah yeah one surprise
yeah because I mean its long tradition
of doom you know launching map pack so
hopefully we'll see more of that and
let's get fallout 4 out of the way do
you think we're gonna see any more I
mean they have a pipeline for a bunch
more expansion packs yeah do you think
they're going to announce anymore i feel
like the cliff on 404 has been here very
surprising i mean so you you host and
run our five four sho right yeah so like
43 seems to just be forever people were
like modding and playing it Skyrim same
sort of thing like I've a similar
experience on my youtube channel doing
fallout 4 like streams and stuff just
you can see it like there's just not
that much interest in it so hi Lisa kind
of plummeted yeah but I was looking at
is the is the time difference between
fallout 3 and New Vegas and write new
vegas was way better than fallout 3 it's
totally my favorite fallout game the gap
there was two years right so in theory
we could see like obsidian Riley they're
hazel are like yeah they take up the
reins the same but happened with fallout
3 and and in Vegas maybe they could be
spoken then you wonder if you know Todd
Herod's team or I guess I wouldn't be
tired ever seeing them but you wonder
maybe if the Fez day as a whole are done
dancing games a year and a half because
they had so much success will fall out
for you true yeah they said that they
when they announced a season pass and
then raise the price of the season they
said they've expanded the scope of it to
include more and if they have more to
work with in terms of they've got more
plans for DLC it wouldn't make sense for
them to announce something now instead
of just being like waiting it out
because as you said interest is kind of
waning and I think that's partially a
symptom of how quickly it was announced
and then released and then just the
amount of hype around with launch she's
very few games again never being
pummeled by fall out stuff already
launched so I think a lot of people like
kind of were ready to draw a line under
faller and be like all right I can sweep
all that stuff yeah on the road now and
move on with my gaming life but like if
they want to bring people back into it
some story DLC will go down a tree or
younkin as let's move on a little bit
here
let's put her through these ones pretty
quick we don't know too much about them
Dishonored 2 we've already seen you know
that lovely trailer pacific game played
this year yeah it definitely would I
went to see it recently woke up a
preview an interview and that kind of
stuff do you see up again played yeah so
I didn't get to play but I watched one
of the game designers play and it looked
really cool it looks to be kind of doing
a lot of similar things but the
interesting thing part of it part of it
is the way the world kind of reacts to
you and the way you can mess around with
weird supernatural powers cool so it's
just a matter of giving you more of that
and making the AI better and the
interesting thing about it was like they
clearly had more ambitious ideas for the
original dishonored rice hampered by
somewhat of the tip by the technology
they couldn't like get the AI routines
down the way they want him to interact
okay and the thing that they were really
speaking about them when i interviewed
them was like we need you know we've got
more power so we can do crazier things
and let you do crazier things so it's
definitely gonna be interesting to see
what they do with it that's exciting I
mean I want a smarter version of thief
or something like that that's right it
feels like to be honest excellent and
wolfenstein will we see another one of
these I mean machine games is rebirth of
that well that's pretty I mean doom was
a surprise what we sign was equally as
yeah I was like what a wonderfully the
best Wolfenstein game is operably right
I'm having yeah yeah do you think we'll
see you anymore well so especially after
that the old world blues that was kind
of like a standalone / DLC experience
but I adored the first well the remake
of of Wolfenstein and especially if they
take the things that they've learned
from doom taking these super old games
kind of dealing onion a style destroying
their 242 yeah now I just want them to
announce a new quake like and I wouldn't
have said that two months ago I would
have said don't touch quake we were all
still remember quake 4 we're still
getting over it and the voice actors for
was hey Anya yes as and she basically
let slip that she's working the second
one the Wolfenstein yeah yes basically
she said I worked on this game series in
the past and i love the bit when you got
to kill Hitler yeah and now I'm working
on this series and I'm working on the
second part of it so like by reading
between the lines spoilers you get to
kill Hitler again
yeah it's interesting you mentioned
quake because the when i played the do
multiplayer right reminded me more of
quake than anything else so that's a
weird thing because like a lot of people
were saying that because I guess the
verticality that existed in quake there
was none in quake one multiplayer and
quake 2 multiplayer it was all like hook
mod and arena stuff and it was like
rocket arena and things like that and
quake 3 was a bit more like Oh does more
people involved but there was an
interesting conversation I had last week
a couple of folks in the office about
how maybe it makes sense that like dooms
multiplayer was the way it was because
they're working on quake like maybe they
just make cuz it's t like for all the
modes and dooms multiplayer our team
based yeah god knows what reason because
team multiplayer was not ever thing I
mean even undo more quake unless you
talk mighty marina which everyone's
wiped from their minds so like imagine
imagine if the reason they got critical
some of your working I was because hey
you know what we're actually gonna be
doing a new quake over here yeah turns
out arena shooters are real hot right
now we got Clippers in ski making new
one Blizzard or even in on it like made
imagine it like now I believe them if
they didn't new quake I've been thrown
my money of that as well right yeah
there's more faith in them no I mean I
totally out there 242 right now they
clearly understand their own lineage
again and yeah they understand what made
the original games great and perhaps
like you've convinced me I'm ready I
believe it so face yeah I was Wesley
facing worlds one of the few CDs are
doing a styler correctly as well yeah
yeah they're not they're not letting you
down they're pulling on your stout heart
strings but then also delivering on that
love yeah it's amazing laughs 20 I guess
last big one here i guess and this one's
been floating around for a while and it
sounds like this is not going to be
anything to do with the one we saw
before which human head was working on
but there is a lot of words that prey to
maybe resurfacing and Jason Trier there
was a he kind of threw it into the end
of one of his news post last week but
then in the comments he added something
else saying is over at Kotaku all I've
heard is that they're announcing it at
e3 I'm not a hundred percent sure though
I do know its code name Danielle and his
under development at arcane Austin and
that this is totally new prey to it
might even be called something else now
at this stage or now sorry now and not
the one we saw in 2011 from human head
so arcane Austin
we don't know what else they're working
on at the moment yeah they haven't I
mean they're a studio that was
established by Bethesda yeah and then
nothing has has come out of it which is
suspicious like they're clearly working
on something and everything that I said
they're kind of jives with what the news
the leaks the kind of rumors that I've
happens real far with you no human had
been taken off the project yeah and even
kind of fits in with Bethesda canceling
the project they canceled pray to rise
in cancer they may have just reinvented
it as something else and taken out all
of that and giving it all Cain Austin
and let them run with it yeah you know
you never know what happens any
situations maybe it wasn't coming
together or yeah i mean i can also have
worked at you know they help that arcane
with a dishonored designer to dr. side
my magic and all that but yeah I'm
ashamed because the human had stuff that
they showed off a few e3's ago yeah
really cool like it look at with you but
you were also wondering I have always
liked is this actually the game yeah
we've been burned a bunch on that a
bunch times I guess the last the they
should probably announce another mobile
game I don't know that last one worked
out pretty good real good we have
shelter I mean that's still on my phone
now yeah it was really good at wasting
my battery d3 when I was on the toilet
like a solid week and sometimes I'm not
so solid week on the toilet for a solid
week oh yeah I am anything else you can
think of Bethesda wise I mean my hopes
is more do more single-player doom and
if they were like four lights on my
favorite game series and I don't mind
admitting that I was a little bit
disappointed before love for you hmm if
they were to revitalize that give it to
obsidian and let them do what they did
to fallout 3 into new vegas yeah that
would make me happy but i wonder if
they're whether we like it or not they
might spend a little time on elder
scrolls online rice yeah i'm sure it's
like looking around I mean it's doing
well enough for them to keep it around
usually MMOs or fail or on doing too
well or can get quicker than this
notarial unlimited they went
free-to-play it's supposed to be doing
okay so maybe we'll get some another the
thieves guild recently survive you'll
get some more stuff to do it you know
more expanded and it's it's almost
thought the fact that we like haven't
talked about this at all but like it is
too early for Todd Herod's team to start
talking about anywhere this girl's game
yeah I don't even think they're a big
team like
as in they have a few people working on
a bunch of different things so they
could be working on him like and put out
a small teaser never know I wouldn't put
it past them don't expect it but I don't
put a wooden plate part like we said
before I mean buzz would all love a scar
and remastered exploring the rest of
that like super rich world yeah there's
still a bunch of provinces and time
really like wife and a half of the
entire world is still unexplored yeah
let's let's get around to that maybe
even like a huge all of Tamriel at once
just give it all to us as much as we
love the Thursday and like to treat
their games as these all these distinct
things they are clearly a lot of like
overlaps between Fallout and Skyrim in
terms of technology how they build the
games the fact that they have done
fallout 4 now makes it considerably
easier to move on to another elder
scroll or maybe that's what the skyrim
you know remastered is all about the
same with Gears of War II a string
running into gears of war for was then
like getting all that at those assets
back it's definitely bleed over in terms
of Technology and design and that kind
of stuff so it would fast-track that
process on what who knows they might
have a new IP up their sleeve as well I
don't the wait and see thank you both
for coming on talking to us Dave Jewish
more saying you stick around we're gonna
stick around I get rob crossley on in a
second and let us know what you think of
Bethesda what they're going to show off
in the comments below and hit that
subscribe button we have a bunch of it
is just eight of these videos going up
on our YouTube channel if you're
watching this live of course you don't
have to wait
you